hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about elements vs. compounds so
how they are different elements versus
compounds are two different ways to
classify matter so the things that make
up the world around us if you're
interested in learning more about
classification of matter including pure
substances versus mixtures see my video
titled classification of matter but now
let's get to talking about elements
elements are something I'm sure you're
familiar with because you've probably
seen the periodic table of elements an
element is defined as a substance that
is composed of only one type of atom so
elements are substances that cannot be
broken down into simpler substances
through natural means so this is really
as simple as matter gets now let's look
at some examples of elements basically
anything you've seen on the periodic
table
sodium copper argon these are examples
of elements sometimes elements exist
bonded to other atoms for example
hydrogen and oxygen are found in what
are called diatomic forms as are many
other gases so this is when there are
two hydrogen atoms bonded together or
two oxygen atoms bonded together but
because they're the same type of atom we
still call these the elemental forms of
these particular substances now if you
are interested in learning about trace
elements in more detail you can see my
video called trace elements and now
let's get to talking about compounds a
compound is a substance that is composed
of two or more elements
so two or more elements so two or more
of these guys and particularly in a
fixed ratio now what does that mean in a
fixed ratio it means that if we look at
examples of compounds every single
compound of methane ch4 has one carbon
and four hydrogen's so there's two
different elements there making it a
compound and you have the same number of
carbons and hydrogen's in every methane
molecule and that's what we mean by in a
fixed ratio again something like carbon
dioxide it's always one carbon and two
oxygens water is always two hydrogen's
and one oxygen this is a type of sugar
with six carbons 12 hydrogen's and two
oxygens we've also got sulfuric acid so
two hydrogen's a sulfur and four oxygens
sodium chloride is one each of sodium
and chlorine so these are all examples
of compounds and you can see that these
are more complex forms of matter than
the elements are by themselves so that
is it for today on biology professor I
hope you learned a lot about elements
and compounds and thanks for watching